[Music]
on this wednesday night
a fall federal election averted
the liberals survive a confidence vote i
vote against the motion i vote against
i vote against the motion but can they
avoid the scrutiny of the we charity
affair
covert 19 cases rise in alberta
voluntary
measures will not be enough why the
province isn't clamping down on
super spreader events big shift from the
catholic church
pope francis's landmark declaration
about same-sex unions
and pursuing support in a swing state
your vote doesn't just matter
it matters more than ever before win
pennsylvania
and potentially win the white house
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
canadians have been spared from a snap
federal election
one year to the day the liberals won
their second mandate
the conservatives despite being backed
by the black quebecois
have been defeated on a motion to form a
special anti-corruption committee
aimed at looking into pandemic spending
reading between the lines
that includes looking into what
connection the prime minister and his
family
had to we charity which at one point was
going to run the student grant program
the prime minister insisted the motion
would set the stage for a confidence
vote
and would force an election nobody
wanted well the nays had it
and the liberal government is staying
put our chief political correspondent
david aiken is in the house of commons
tonight david did the
ndp save canadians from a snap election
well indeed they did rob and for those
who did not want an election and polls
say that was a majority of canadians you
know
drug meat sing the ndp leader was saying
before the vote that you know he thought
it was absurd
that the prime minister decided to make
a motion
that simply would have created a
parliamentary committee into
a confidence matter it's simply never
been done before but that said
singing the ndp say they still believe
that there are other ways to
hold the government to account over
their actions involving the we charity
as well as spending related to the
pandemic
we are voting for canadians we are
voting against an election we are
going to continue to work for people and
that means
continuing to hold the government to
account
now the conservatives also thought that
the pm had
vastly overreached declaring their
motion uh to be a matter of confidence
uh
nonetheless the conservatives in the
blockade because you mentioned they
voted in favor
they were on the losing side
conservative leader aaron o'toole though
had this warning for the prime minister
we're here to ask questions in
accordance with our role as an
opposition party
and we are never going to let
the arrogance or entitlement of the
liberal party
to stand in our way of asking reasonable
questions
that canadians want us to ask
now what was trudeau's problem well he
tried to argue that
had this committee been created by the
conservatives
that that would have paralyzed
parliament
we don't want an election canadians
don't want an election but canadians
need to know
that their parliament continues to work
constructively
now let's talk about the we controversy
does that go away now
no it does not go away but the
investigation into the we charity and
the
liberal actions gets folded i think into
the broader considerations of
other government pandemic spending and
that would include
what the opposition is calling the
latest scandal and that scandal
involves the awarding of a contract for
ventilators
a contract worth 270 million dollars to
a montreal company
that was just recently incorporated and
one of its principles just happens to be
someone who a year ago was in the
liberal caucus
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson mercedes did the
liberals actually want this election to
happen
that's a great question robin was it
pandemic hardball to avoid scrutiny
or were the liberals willing to go to an
election well certainly the opposition
believes the liberals wanted an election
even though we have heard
prime minister justin trudeau and others
deny it at the end of the day
only the liberals know what their true
intention was here but i can tell you
that sources we've spoken to say that
this aggressive
and brash statement of actually taking
this to a confidence vote
meant the threat was real that the
government felt they were not bluffing
on this
and they were willing to go to the polls
if they needed to
one senior liberal source told me the
liberals felt they could do quite well
on an election platform
of pandemic spending child care and
pharmacare if they did have to face
canadians
the liberals seemed rather confident
about turning this non-confidence vote
their way haven't they essentially
backed the opposition into a corner
well what mattered here was less whether
the liberals wanted an election and more
the fact that they knew the opposition
did not and that's where you're getting
at when you talk about backing them into
a corner aaron o'toole
relative unknown still and the
conservatives don't have their platform
ready
the ndp have no money and run the risk
of winning fewer seats
and the ndp had already publicly said as
well robin that they didn't think it was
responsible
to have an election during a pandemic
the opposition knew that canadians would
likely blame
them if the government fell even though
it was a liberal to liberals who
triggered a confidence vote here
uh and in that case it was something
they were very wary of
even so this puts the country into
perpetual
election threat mode let's remind
canadians that exactly a year ago they
voted in a minority government
i remember where i was a year ago very
well the question here is whether the
liberals are going to keep
using this strategy when they are
exposed to scrutiny
or to questions that they don't like
will the government try to bully the
opposition like this
by threatening an election instead of
opening up their books and being
transparent
these confidence votes have come in a
very short period of time
and it's a strategy that could become
unwelcome for the liberals
if they keep going down this path as
always good talking to you mercedes
stephenson
in ottawa to the kova 19 pandemic now
british columbia is reporting a record
number of new cases today
for the first time more than 200 people
in that province have tested positive
within 24 hours next door alberta is
also setting a record
with more than 400 new infections
tonight premier jason kenney and several
mlas are self-isolating
after a cabinet minister came into
contact with someone who has the virus
and still the government is relying on
albertans to take it upon themselves
to limit gatherings in large groups
premier kennedy doesn't want the
province to enforce its way out
but as heather yorks west explains
experts say something isn't done soon
the health system will be in a crisis
before christmas alberta's second wave
of kovid 19
is approaching a critical juncture i
would say right now we're in a danger
zone
where the coming weeks will really tell
that story about whether we are able
collectively
to bend that curve downwards by
following all of that guidance that's
already out there
alberta's coveted 19 cases have been
surging since early october
there are more active cases right now
than during the province's previous peak
in april and may
that's led to a record number of coveted
19 patients being hospitalized
with 120 hospitalizations reported last
week
compared to the previous high of 93 in
late july
the royal alec is now reinstituting
their covert
units because of the number of
hospitalized patients and
as you increase the density of the virus
within the hospital you also increase
the risk
of outbreaks outbreaks have already been
declared at four alberta hospitals
but within the province's big cities the
source of many infections is still
not known contact tracers are working to
track several so-called
super spreader events including a
wedding that led to more than 40 people
becoming sick
at these events covid19 has spread
quickly and dramatically among
well-meaning people
taking action to flatten the curve is in
the hands of 4.4 million albertans in
the actions that they take
as individuals we call upon those
albertans to exercise personal
responsibility
alberta's premier has so far resisted
calls to implement any new restrictions
beyond voluntary measures that were
introduced in edmonton almost
two weeks ago since then growth has
slowed
but perhaps not enough to reverse the
tide clearly
people are not sticking to the
guidelines and numbers are rising and
something has to be done otherwise we
will be looking at
a health crisis before christmas heather
urex west global news calgary
the federal government says canada has
received its first shipment of a hundred
thousand
rapid tests for covet 19. they can
deliver results in as little as 13
minutes
the tests will be sent to the provinces
but it's still not clear
which ones will get them in toronto
there is an outbreak at st michael's
hospital where there are five active
coronavirus cases among emergency room
staff
the facility remains open to those
needing care but anyone who visited the
er within the last two weeks
should self-monitor saint joseph's
health center toronto western hospital
and the center for addiction and mental
health are also dealing
with covet-19 outbreaks ottawa public
health has identified
five outbreaks involving organized
sports teams
so far there are 28 confirmed kova 19
cases
linked to these outbreaks but hundreds
of others could potentially have been
exposed
health officials say transmission took
place with teams involving both adults
and children infections have been linked
to carpooling to and from practice
sharing locker rooms and socializing
after play
in ontario sports teams are not allowed
to play games or scrimmages
they're only permitted to practice
the manitoba government is increasing
fines for people and business owners
who ignore public health orders the fine
for individuals will jump from 486
to 1296 dollars for businesses and
corporations the penalty will climb from
just over twenty five hundred dollars to
five thousand dollars
the fines apply to people who don't self
isolate when they should
and businesses that exceed capacity
limits
less than two weeks before the u.s
election and coven 19 cases are surging
in that country
in the past week there have been more
than 420 000 new cases
and no states are reporting any decline
in infection rates
as jackson prosco reports there's
concern about
how bad things will get just as millions
of americans gather
to vote the dreaded fall surge is
ravaging middle america
pushing hospitals to the brink as sick
patients flood icus
they are significantly more sick than
the ones that we saw
in the beginning of this pandemic cases
are on the rise or alarmingly high in
most states
the u.s is now recording nearly 60
thousand new cases per day
and is on course to set an all-time
record for new infections in the days
before the november 3rd election
what does the situation in the u.s look
like in the beginning of november
it looks worse than it does today
because
we are not taking the precautions and as
people say
we're fatigued people are pandemic out
you know that they're pandemiced out
with more than 220 thousand americans
dead and with his own job on the line
president donald trump has shown no
interest in changing course
is there anything that you think you
could have done differently if you had a
mulligan or a do-over on one aspect of
the way you handled it
what would it be not much trump is still
holding tightly packed rallies in covit
19 hot spots
and urging states to ease restrictions
local officials are left to face a
fractured skeptical public
is this virus even a real deal is this
the biggest hoax ever
so that's what we're dealing with there
are no quick fixes in sight
and win or lose on november 3rd trump
will still preside over what could be
the darkest days of the pandemic in the
fall and winter
it isn't clear yet what the policies of
this administration are
overwhelmed states are left to worry
about even tougher days
ahead with their ability to cope already
stretched to the limit
jackson proskow global news washington
barack obama has hit the campaign trail
in philadelphia to support joe biden
the former president could be a key
asset for the democratic nominee to
clinch crucial swing states
our mike armstrong is in battleground
pennsylvania tonight
mike this is obama's first appearance in
this campaign why is he stepping up now
well robin barack obama's plan after
leaving office was to avoid
politics and in particular to avoid
criticizing his successor
well plans change well obama has taken
part in campaign videos and tv ads with
his former vice president
but tonight's rally in philadelphia will
be his first in-person event
he released a video last evening in
advance in times as polarized as these
your vote doesn't just matter it matters
more than ever before
the biden campaign strategy is to use
obama to hit battleground states where
early voting is already underway
even a small bump for biden could make a
difference in some states here in
pennsylvania a state with more than 6
million
votes in 2016 donald trump won by less
than
one percent well trump was in eerie
pennsylvania tuesday night it was at
times
unconventional trump telling the crowd
he's only behind in the polls
because of covid19 before the plague
came in i had it made
i wasn't coming to erie i i mean i have
to be honest there's no way i was coming
i didn't have to i would have called you
and said hey erie you know if you have a
chance get out but we had this thing won
now trump also went after biden's roots
in pennsylvania biden grew up in the
state but trump says he left when he was
young and
isn't really from pennsylvania robin as
it turns out we have a look at
biden's roots in this state we visited
his boyhood home in scranton this week
that story is up later
in the show all right thanks for that
mike mike armstrong in pennsylvania
the mounties mount a defense coming up
the rcmp's top boss defends the response
to nova scotia's
lobster dispute
to the lobster fishing dispute in nova
scotia now for the first time the rcmp's
top boss is speaking publicly about the
crisis
that has escalated between indigenous
and commercial fissures
commissioner brenda lockey says extra
resources have been brought in to keep
the community
caught in the middle safe but the
mounties are still being criticized for
their response
here's ross lord rcmp commissioner
brenda lucky says
she wants to reassure canadians her
organization is on top of the lobster
crisis
we are fully committed to keeping the
peace
keeping people safe and enforcing the
law that mandate has been called into
question
especially after rcmp officers stood by
last week
as angry commercial fishers vandalized
lobster pounds
forcing a sebago naggity first nation
harvester to barricade himself inside
the commissioner defends her
organization we can't be
in every single location but when we are
there and when we are made aware of
those actions we will
step in we will intervene except it
seems for when they don't
i think the general consensus everywhere
is that the rcmp slipped up and now it's
just they're scrambling how are they
going to recover
the videos show it rcmp standing there
watching crimes being committed
days later a lobster pound that did
business with indigenous fishers
was destroyed by a suspected arsonist a
man considered a person of interest was
sent to hospital with what rcmp called
life-threatening injuries tensions have
eased in recent days
but thorny questions remain like how to
untangle federal
support for a moderate livelihood
fishery from provincial law
that forbids the sale of first nations
lobster because it's not licensed by
fisheries and oceans canada
well it points at the core of the issue
here is that under existing canadian law
the activity in saint mary's bay is
clearly illegal
sebagneggity has won a legal victory of
sorts
obtaining a temporary injunction against
interference at the sonyaville wharf
the wharf has become a home base for
first nations boats and supporters
another development on the long road to
order resolution
ross lord global news halifax
purdue pharma the manufacturer of the
powerful painkiller oxycontin
has reached a plea deal in the u.s the
drug maker pleaded guilty to three
criminal charges
for paying doctors to write more
prescriptions and misleading regulators
about its efforts to restrict
overprescribing the drug
the company will pay the u.s government
225 million dollars
part of an 8 billion dollar penalty
produ pharma is blamed for sparking the
deadly opioid crisis
that has killed almost half a million
people in the u.s
still ahead the pope's shift on same-sex
unions
we are able to have tests
oh my god there's an earthquake a 5.6
magnitude earthquake interrupted
iceland's prime minister while she was
giving an
interview on the impact of the pandemic
on tourism
but katja jacob's daughter kept her cool
quickly moving on by saying well
this is iceland pope francis has called
for the creation of civil unions for
same-sex couples
his stance breaks from the catholic
church's official teachings
the pontiff made the comments in a new
documentary based on his life called
francesco
francis says same-sex couples should be
legally covered
but he stopped short of advocating for
legalized marriage
the pope says homosexual people have the
right to be in a family
they are children of god italy was the
last country in western europe other
than vatican city
to offer same-sex couples legal rights
africa's largest city is under a strict
and indefinite curfew
after weeks of protests against police
brutality in nigeria
but demonstrators are showing their
defiance even in the face of gunfire
amnesty international says it's
investigating credible evidence that
multiple people were killed yesterday
witnesses reported seeing uniformed men
shooting into the crowds demonstrations
first broke out two weeks ago over
alleged abuse by the country's
now disbanded special anti-robbery squad
the government is vowing to restore
order
up next sowing the seeds in scranton can
biden grow support from his
pennsylvania roots
pennsylvania has emerged as a swing
state that could be a factor in the
outcome of the u.s presidential election
in 2016 donald trump won pennsylvania's
20 electoral college votes
in a narrow victory that paved his way
to the white house
but his rival joe biden grew up there
and as mike armstrong
explains the democrat is determined to
win
his home state it's not on any tourism
websites but this home
may be someday the reason people stop
for pictures
is that the wood slotted house on
scranton's washington avenue
was the boyhood home of a man who may be
the next president
joe biden hey buddy how are you biden
hasn't forgotten this home he dropped by
on the campaign trail this summer
it's time for a few questions no no i
just didn't see hands
now that and he wanted to see is the new
homeowner sort of
it's hard to call ann kearns new
considering she raised a family in the
home and has lived in it for close to
six
decades he's been here now i think about
11
12 times kearns has documented some of
those trips including the first one
biden brought his 91 year old mother in
2016 he popped by with journalists in
tow
and then presidential candidate hillary
clinton
the goal of that visit was to help
clinton in central pennsylvania
it didn't work donald trump's victory in
this state in 2016 by the slimmest of
margins
was thanks to votes he picked up in
rural and blue-collar communities
this time around joe biden's playing up
his blue-collar roots
just about every chance he gets i view
this campaign
as i've said before and i'll say it
again between scranton and park
avenue biden only lived in scranton
until he was 10. his family moved away
in 1953
as part of a massive exodus when the
steel mills closed
i like the guy now it's not hard to find
scrantonians who are proud of biden
but there are those who say he's trying
to take advantage of shallow
roots i knew joe when we were kids did
you really yeah
the green ridge speed so we went in
there for pete so
but joe left and joe never came back
well he's come back enough for visits
that the kearns family regrets a change
they made years ago
as a boy biden had carved joe was here
in the molding of this window
we not knowing he was gonna be vice
president someday had removed that
so when he was here we said you know
we'd love it if you uh resigned uh
the old home so that was where joe
signed on top of everything else that's
on the line in this election there's
even more for the kearns family
the next two weeks will determine
whether the house eventually becomes an
official
tourist attraction mike armstrong global
news
scranton pennsylvania and that is global
national for this wednesday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the harbor in victoria bc
we'd love to see your corner of the
country so send us your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow and i'll see
you
this weekend have a great night
you